[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hey we've got a lot to get to today uh
but uh this one is for the girls this
one's for the ladies I just want you to
keep an open mind if you're a lady right
now watching or listening um we'll be
talking about Joe Biden of course
creepypeto Joe he is what he is right
but you can't blame a snake for being a
snake we want to talk about today is the
advice of no serious guys until you're
30 and that this is echoed from the left
um
the problem you know we've talked about
how people shut down dialogue before it
begins that's why it's such that's why
it's such a pervasive problem when
you're dealing with everything's racism
everything's homophobia everything's
sexism everything is transphobia
feminists have really painted women into
a corner
women who don't follow lockstep with
third wave feminism you're seeing the
factions that are sort of being created
right now because we've been told as men
we're not allowed an opinion for a very
long amount of time
I don't agree with that we'll express
our opinions today but I want to know
I think you need to laser in a question
when you're talking about ideology
um
has any of this to you out there if
you're a feminist if you're a first wave
second wave whatever whatever you want
to call yourself
the idea that we value that women should
value
um profession over family the idea that
we exalt women that we build up women by
telling them that they are equivalent to
men
in male dominated areas and there's a
byproduct there right is it is it nature
is it nurture the idea that we tell them
and you're just as good as a man at X
when we know it's not true that you
should value X instead of Y we
fundamentally changed what it is
that a lot of women seek in life
and if you believe that gender is a
societal construct you'd have to believe
that some of your motivations are
byproduct of societal constructs I think
the litmus test here is and this is what
we want to get into today has any of
this made your life better
are you better off
are you happier
I'm pretty fortunate and they have a
really large sample size with the show
that we do the tens of millions of
people each month and we get a lot of
letters we get a lot of comments and
it's a problem that I know I hear you
the women who reach out and say how do I
speak with my feminist friend about X
because your shutdown is being
anti-woman even if you're a woman at
this point
look I don't think we're helping anyone
I don't think we're helping trans people
I don't think that we're helping any
marginalized class and I certainly don't
think that we're helping women if
ultimately the solutions that are being
provided are ultimately the values that
are being espoused have not made your
life better
a lot of men are frustrated they're
checking out of the marriage pool and a
lot of young women are frustrated
because they find themselves at 35 40
years old having having followed the
advice of a Joe Biden so I just ask that
you keep an open mind
before you go ah mansplaining and ask
yourself hold on a second
is there something being discussed today
that may make my life better
because women are less happy
than ever in modern recorded history
what we are doing is not working
and I think that's really sad as a
father of a daughter that's what we're
going to get into today also jokes about
wieners okay let's do the show
trick or treat look at you you're
Spider-Man we got a red riding hood and
what are you are you a dinosaur oh that
is adorable okay hold on I got something
for you Uncle Stephen
came prepared
where the candy no that's that's better
than candy that's that's a three month
emergency food supply kit from my
Patriot Supply it's got everything you
need in case of some kind of an
emergency or natural disaster and all
the nutrition that you guys need to grow
big and strong for when Skynet Falls
okay parents didn't tell you about
Skynet when the robots turn on the human
race ending civilization as we know what
a nuclear Armageddon all right again
if you want anything you'll probably be
burned up and vaporized before you even
know what's happening besides it doesn't
just have to be Armageddon there are a
million reasons to be prepared
especially when you can get the food
supply from prep with crowder.com
they're taking 250 off for three month
kids uh it could be anything floods
earthquakes ice storms riots race Wars
pestilence how are we supposed to carry
this I don't know maybe that's a
question better suited to your future
robot overlords smart enough
go to prepwithcrowder.com and save 250
off of any three-month emergency food
kit you need today that's the lowest
price in three years
spooky low
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
there's no sip there because I'm running
down a sorry an important note for
today's show
no vagina no opinion I just crossed it
out remember that
so we have a lot to get to today we
wanted to prepare you know we kept our
powder dry a little bit because
obviously it was trending you know a
former Vice President Joe Biden being
the very least creepy with a young girl
but uh I I think there's something more
to it that a lot of people have been
missing so my question to you before we
do anything else is out of all the
things that uh former Vice President Joe
Biden has done that that are gross right
we all agree uh which one sticks out to
you the most
like which one in your in your mind's
eye makes you oh oh that doesn't feel
right
it's a tough choice to make I know it is
yeah
it's tough it was the biker chick on the
lap I think it's one of those things
where maybe we have to split the baby
because there's just so much that is
wrong with it all right so we'll be
talking about that we'll be talking
about the failed foreign policy that's
going on right now with Saudi Arabia gas
prices what the left is doing before the
midterms the state of the economy uh and
of course unmugly playing Photoshop or
not but really young women right now are
miserable
and it's not a good thing for anybody
it's not a good thing for women it's not
a good thing for men so a little bit
macro today the kids call it I think a
deep dive don't know if I should use
that term today but you understand where
I'm coming from Gerald a how are you sir
I'm doing well I'm not miserable and I'm
not a young woman good for you here we
go well that's that female privilege I
identify as Trends I don't oh okay well
you said it
the car I can't argue with that but I
can't argue with myself apparently yes
Italian [ __ ] out cruising yeah Rock Z
baby and uh you hear him you know him
you love him fastest man on his feet
we're on tour here together we have two
shows that still have tickets left
through the end of the year uh November
12th at Ryman Auditorium we added a
second show at 9 30. uh for tickets go
to lotuscrutter.com tour yeah Dave
Lindell how are you Ahoy good not many
left I just checked yeah I just checked
so check coming to Nashville seriously
it's gonna be an amazing show it's the
balcony seats I think that are yes yeah
there's a there's a couple in the main
but they're sort of sporadic yeah I hope
they wish they would figure out a way to
mash them together so yeah sit with your
wife well you think they could do that
because there are no seats at The Rime
and it's just the benches yeah like
which I just have somebody slide over
yeah look at that that's an amazing
theater isn't it hopefully I don't end
up having like you know cardiac arrest
on stage but I will give a camera the
finger well that's all that matters It's
a grand a lot it's the original Grand
Library isn't that what it is isn't the
original one then they changed it well
when you say these things yes I believe
so I have no idea I know it's Legend
research right off the bat could be
talking out my rear all right let's go
to this so uh before we move we have a
lot we're really gonna spend some time
here on Joe Biden's advice to young
women and why everything about it is
wrong but first and I should warn you
we're not showing you this because uh
it's titillating which at first glance
you might think why are we showing this
just wait till the end
this 23 year old uh Tick Tock influencer
because that's a job now is is really
not known for anything other than
showing her than showing then showing
the um showing
um showing her breasts uh for millions
of views and dollars and um guess what
she has a number one fan it's not who
you think
watch this watch this you ready
baggy boom
[Music]
kids are stupid
so I never thought I'd be advocating for
fatherless homes we've been wrong this
whole time here we are that's your dad
that's her dad third person who walks in
the police yes she would hope so I could
Lord just a police cover band who are
taking part yeah just jumping in you
've gone on a red
either way that psychological trauma is
going to leave a sting oh yeah
wow this is this Dad this is where we
are right now because we're so busy
concerned with being friends and
accommodating we've talked about this
narcissism what it is that what it is it
feels right for you that's what
parenting is now it's about supporting
whatever feels I just threw up in my
mouth a little a little that made me
throw up in my mouth a little bit he's
he's encouraging his daughter to be
a [ __ ] essentially for for dollars I
just would not essentially yeah
literally literally doing that yeah
that's your own conversation though like
he's at home like honey you're not
really good at anything
but you have those yeah so maybe use
those and I'll even be in your video I'm
a fan and I'm like do you not she said
you weren't born with much of a brain
you better start using your body yeah
well see yeah honey you're what they
call a 2AM 7. yes and uh I think we can
make it work for you yes at uh other
times but yes let's turn your low
self-confidence into a feature yes let's
uh and I'll dance in there with you yes
for some reason all my friends don't
talk to me anymore right and your your
mother left yes my only friend is child
protective services and Johnny wants to
know if he can go on a date with you but
he's 57 and he's your brother now time
to have dinner while somebody monitors
it Jesus
yeah it's a game of Clue guess why she
became a stripper this is back in our
day she would have been on the pole in
the dead of night in the darkness where
she belongs
what have we done speaking of which uh
uh I don't know that there's a Segway uh
here's a clip of former Vice President
Joe Biden
the first thing I told my daughter and
granddaughters no serious guys were 30.
what no serious guys to your 30s
now I know you at first glance that
seems really bad but he also went on to
um you know he's actually qualified as a
finishing school instructor he went on a
teacher etiquette I have to go for life
I have to be polite
Pink Floyd
that's another rule
but it's good advice it's a live show by
the way Monday through Thursday
10 a.m Eastern if you want to tune in
here not only on YouTube and we're off
YouTube uh nothing but maybe happier
than all of you going over to rumble of
course mug Club will be playing
Photoshop or not an extra full 100 of
show that's a percentage right there
ready to just take the show and say it's
times two Monday through Thursday a lot
of credit.com the mug Club
ah boy
okay did you see how awkward that girl
felt though yeah she was very
uncomfortable oh man can we all agree I
mean are you sure are we or is it
conjecture at this point are we
speculating no yeah she's uncomfortable
yeah she's the mom because you hear her
go yeah we'll keep that in mind very
like Angry yeah well every if every girl
that he touches like instinctively pulls
away that should tell you something yes
and that's what she's doing she's like
uh I took a picture with the president
but that's all I wanted Joe dude I
didn't want a hand on the shoulder in a
creepy way right Keanu Reeves takes
every picture like he's doing jazz hands
yeah you're not supposed to touch people
that's kind of the deal now exactly
unless it's like with their permission
right you the hover hands like she has
ghost shoulder pads yes
I do that you'll see a lot of pictures
of like this oh that's why I go like
this so people are like why are you
doing this they're like number one or
thumbs up it's like so that you can see
where the hands are exactly like back
when I used to watch Three's Company
yeah that's true I put my hand anywhere
and I just go no one will believe
I always be polite let me look genuine
only of course okay we'll move on from
this but I do have to ask you if you're
a dad you have a daughter if that's your
wife
anyone other than former Vice President
Joe Biden let's just get rid of all the
white noise here from the media and oh
you know there it is this is political
this is political theater
what would you do would you be okay with
that if that was your daughter nope
I really want to hear from you and what
if you're a young girl would you be
comfortable with that when we talk about
you know taking precautions and making
sure that women are comfortable he's
just look behind you you've blown way
past the line
I have nieces and a goddaughter and
friends with daughters and that made me
uncomfortable well based on his diary I
think uh I think there was he's probably
comfortable with doing a lot more
touching than we uh right we which the
FBI has not confirmed nor denied nor
denied but they did get mad at the
people who stole it and say they stole a
real diet thanks for confirming it yeah
yeah I know you read my diary was a
felony yes exactly people who don't know
Ashley Biden talked about showering with
her dad beyond the point when it was
age-appropriate yes this is not a
conspiracy she wrote it down and the FBI
kind of like was Elon Omar banging her
brother Reuters and uh Snopes were like
well we weren't able to confirm it so
it's not not true that's kind of your
job is to confirm it yeah just you know
here's a marriage certificate ah your
guess is as good as mine we really don't
know oh believe all women well it's a
diary yeah it's only an account of what
happened just her deepest most Intimate
Secrets the search continues
it's like where's Waldo got the diary
draped and candy cane wrapping paper in
the peppermint Farm only Diaries and
traumatized accurate proof of what just
happened right I mean you have the
account that she wrote down Ashley Biden
and then of course you have her entire
life and behavioral choices as
substantiating evidence
yeah we can't do that no that's what we
that's what we call a deadlock for a bet
so look we all know Joe Biden and I want
to ask us we all know that he's creepy I
I don't want to say uh pedophile gives
off the vibe I cannot confirm that but
it's we all know that okay but I think
people are missing something
here
and no one's really talked about it
maybe someone has the advice that he
gives this young woman
is not only indicative of his character
uh he's trying to use it as an in with a
little girl it's horrible
for women
it really and this is this is indicative
of the heart of the democratic party of
the people like Joe Biden of the Kamal
hairs they don't want you happy
they don't want you in a they don't
really have a fulfilling life with your
own nuclear family basically your own
microcosm of an Effective Government
because they believe it takes a village
they want you to be dependent on the
village so let's go back I want to watch
that clip again
just now I want you to watch this
through the lens of listening to his
advice
now very important thing I told my
daughter and granddaughter
no serious guys are 30.
no serious guys to your 30.
or when you're past 30 you can just do
like Jill and uh pick me
20 30 you can you settle down because
nobody's gonna want that right was
someone saying at least yeah somebody
said at least somebody said at least
you're 21 years past your Prime at that
point right
you let Gordie Howe playing with his son
you're there but it doesn't matter
anymore
so here's the thing it's not just former
Vice President Joe Biden you see this
from a lot of cultural institutions from
people in the media let me read you some
headlines so from pop sugar why you
should absolutely wait until after 30 to
get married uh Brides I guess is a
magazine why getting married in your 30s
is The New Normal Elite Daily five good
reasons why you should wait until you're
30 to get married author Joy Chen don't
marry before you are 30. you hear this a
lot okay so let's walk through this for
a second
um and we'll be taking your chat here in
mug Club I think this is an important
conversation to have this means that
young women aren't even supposed to look
at serious relationships until they're
30. now before I do some math yes I get
it male privilege right can we all okay
white male privilege yeah there we go
okay so we're not supposed to have an
opinion but there's biology here that
does matter and it is true there is a
different standard for women than there
is for men the consequences are more
catastrophic because you do have a
biological window and you do have a
choice to make men have choices to make
in different facets you do have a choice
to make you can't have all of the things
yeah you can't become a CEO of the most
powerful company well into your 30s and
then want to be or you can but the
chances are slim a mother you can't go
through second adolescence and then also
be equipped if you only start looking
for serious relationships when you are
30 be equipped for a serious
relationship so let's do some math here
they're not supposed to start looking
at serious guys until they're 30. that's
what he said right no serious guys until
you're three so the median length of
dating and all references are available
at lotto.com before engagement is about
three and a half years 3.3 years to be
exact okay so now you're at 33 and a
half let's call it 33. the average
engagement lasts 12 to 18 months
let's call it here okay now you're at 34
and a half then the average amount of
time that people wait to have children
after marriage is three years
so now you're looking on the low low end
37.5 more likely 39. so assuming that
you follow the former vice president's
advice
Mr Wright as they call them uh if you
were to meet the perfect man meaning
immediately when you turn 30 and you
have not been looking at any serious
relationships if you hit the lottery and
immediately meet Mr Wright you're still
on average at the soonest looking at
becoming a mother
at 37 years old
I know somebody's going to say well not
all women want to be mothers great I
understand this isn't for you your
opinion may change in five years which
is something that we'll get to but this
is a biological reality if you follow
that advice 37 years old is when you
would be looking at starting your life
as a mother if you understand the
consequences that we're about to I'm
going to just hit the like button it
helps with the algorithm here on YouTube
um
full disclosure of course I think is is
more Christian conservatives I don't
think that's a good idea I don't think
you should be getting married at 16 or
18. but you know we do believe in the
woman of our youth that is ideal yeah
absolutely not Jerry Lee Lewis right
[Music]
there's got to be a happy medium there's
got to be a happy medium you can't look
I I was a guy who was looking for a
serious relationship my wife was looking
for a serious relationship for a long
time trying to find the right person I
didn't think it would happen for you it
you didn't you thought Coldplay and
track lighting spelled something else
yes and that was a lonely Gerald that
still spells it no no no no it really
doesn't I have a wife now also the fact
that you slept in a race car well that's
that's a personal choice that I will
defend not a bad just a race you just
slept in a race car saw some dinosaur
sheets in there like come on there's no
Synergy it takes time like really it
takes time to find somebody and then you
are in a position where we were we're
thank God my wife is a little bit
younger than me so this works out a
little bit better for us but she was
getting closer to that time where okay
it's going to be more difficult yeah if
I wait too much longer we had kids you
know we we got married we met got
married a year later and then then had
the largest baby known to man had a
child yes yeah he's a baby when I was
like oh he's one I'm like he's one yeah
he was like how old do you think it was
like three a half I don't know he's
doing pull-ups he's doing the Iron Cross
I thought he's watching Honey I Blew Up
the Kid movies no I think it's honey I
blew up the baby baby Honey I Shrunk the
cake baby honey baby sorry we have to
get the yeah we have to get the camera
the cannon of honey yeah series correct
the Honey's down got it then there's
honey I got punched in the Upper West
Side yes for Rick Moranis yeah honey The
Knockout game yeah oh gosh that was
tragic
so 37 years old okay 37 years old is
when you're looking at becoming a mother
at this point if you follow Joe Biden's
advice that is when 90 percent
of your eggs are gone
okay so here you go the references are
available and these are these are I mean
I can say these are published medical
journals but it's not like this is
something when people say this is agreed
upon in the scientific Community when
they say that meaning like puberty
blockers are mostly okay well we haven't
tested yet we haven't tested that yet
it's still a hypothesis now this is
something that you can very easily
measure so this is something that is
agreed upon because it is correct we can
actually test to see the levels of
fertility so here's a quote from it we
estimate that for 95 percent of women by
the age of 30 years only 12 percent of
their maximum pre-birth ngf population
is present and by the age of 40 only
three percent remains now uh birth
complications of course go up
dramatically the risk of down syndrome
35 year olds are four and a half times
more likely than 25 year olds the risk
of stillbirth right they're about 1.3
times more likely if you're 35 to 40
years old compared to people who are 19
to 34. there are higher risks of uh
gestational diabetes uh preeclampsia
premature birth right requiring a
C-section miscarriages now here's why I
bring this up it's not that you have to
be a mother her to be happier to be
fulfilled as a woman but you need to
understand
that there is an option that becomes a
more distant reality the older that you
get and I don't think that we are doing
young women a service by hiding that and
by not bringing up the it's the same
thing where we talked about children on
Purity blockers you need to weigh the
risks and rewards of course John Oliver
comes past in some instances it may lead
to sterility well hold on a second
that's a pretty serious consequence
if you think that motherhood is
something that you want as a part of
your life you absolutely cannot be
waiting to look for a serious guy until
you're 30. also something that can't be
statistically observed I'm willing to
bet that the kinds of guys who you would
want to be a father at the age of 30 are
more difficult to come by and here's the
issue ultimately this is all part of the
big lie they want to say the big lie
that this wasn't the most Fair free
secure election of all time the big lie
that you can have it all that women you
need to re you need to reshuffle your
priorities namely meaning place a
premium on workplace success it's
enslaved women to the workplace and
robbed them of some of life's most
fulfilling experiences namely being a
wife namely being a mother ask women who
are mothers
not the ones who had crack babies that
they throw off the curve well they've
made being a moment right you know what
I mean they've turned it into something
that it's like oh you don't want to do
that that's going to tie you down and
make it's like do you understand what it
means to be a mom or to be a parent to
be a father this is not an inconvenience
this is a life mission for people you
will never do anything I don't care what
company you run you will never do
anything more fulfilling than being a
parent ever in your life there is
nothing on the planet that can do that
for you and I know who hasn't climbed
Kilimanjaro or Everest yeah whatever but
I'm serious like you can have
experiences that are fantastic you can
do things that leave an impact on
civilization for a very long time with
inventing new technologies or maybe you
know figuring out world peace I don't
know but you will never do anything like
sowing into the Next Generation as a
parent and people oftentimes don't find
this out until it's way too and you know
why because I try and shut down people
like Gus because oh you're a white male
uh as though we're saying this is the
only way for you to be happy as though
we're saying that all women have to be
mothers no no but you need to have have
a realistic assessment of your options
and there has been a systematic
corrosion of that from the left not only
through feminism and free love right in
the idea that you can Empower women by
turning them into more sexually
predatorial creatures like men that one
kind of backfired the whole free the
nipple boy that's the greatest reverse
psychology that's ever been pulled on
behalf of men you aren't going to sit
screw you we're going to show it like oh
no please don't
let me get my camera so that and then of
course the pushing of of abortion which
by the way can also increase the
likelihood of birth complications this
idea that we liberate women by trying to
create them in the image of men women
don't often there are exceptions just to
be clear want the same things that men
want statistically women
have more regrets if they don't have
children by the way there's a lot of
data out there what we've been doing
since the 1960s isn't working women and
girls in the western world are more
unhappy than they've ever been over the
last 35 years there are a bunch of
Statistics but some antidepressant use
that's up 65 percent from 1999 to 2014.
uh women are twice as likely to use them
as men I know you can argue that maybe
because men don't get help okay but
again we're talking about comparing
women to then and now suicidality in
girls has increased 12 percent annually
from 2007 to 2014 and then you see on
the flip side of that because of divorce
laws again a lot of that has been pushed
by the left because of this idea that
marriage is something that really isn't
a binding contract men are checking out
of the marriage pool
close to 40 percent
so if you're looking for a man no
serious guys until you're 40. well guess
what you're probably looking about 40
percent at least it's probably higher in
men over men over the age of 30 who
don't want to get married
and now you're scrambling you're racing
against the clock you've been chasing
the wrong things it's so isn't it kind
of funny that when you watch every
Disney film and you see these these
leftist films it's always the business
owner right if the businessman shows up
he's bad he's yeah yeah it's a Harry
Chapin song right oh he only cares about
business Dad can't come to my basketball
game because he's at work when it's a
woman however that should be your
singular Pursuit because that's where
you find self-worth all I want
especially for my daughter and I've been
thinking about this a lot is for her to
have a choice and for her to be
accurately not a choice to kill somebody
else to have a choice as it relates to
her own life if she wants to go become a
CEO and forego being a mom and a wife
fine that's her choice but I want her to
understand the consequences right and
there's been one side that has been
cloaking the consequences because they
have a financially vested interest in
you being enslaved to the workforce or
ultimately being beholden to the
government and that comes to the form of
student loans that come I mean right
there's there's a lit of examples that
we could um we could list for you uh
it's really concerning and sure we see
creepypeto Joe being creepy former vice
president pedo Joe but the advice is
reflective
of unfortunately a cultural undercurrent
that is making women less happy than
ever it's not working yeah well I think
pedo Joe is also I mean what not former
vice president yeah yeah respect the
office right sorry
um we may have just been trying to make
a joke and you know because when he was
a born people really only lived to be
30. right
[Laughter]
they have like 12 kids because like well
four of them will get kicked by a horse
yeah you never know polio is the other
four yeah and then they gotta have two
more to make up for the eighth that died
from horse and polio yep that's making a
comeback now yeah big time and it's uh
foreign
thanks Jenny McCarthy we appreciate that
yes I think there's also a problem with
arrested developments in our entire
generation and I say that dressed like
this
um it's uh but it really is I think it's
uh I think it's Gen X uh Millennials
then you go into gen whatever z z who's
just you know and yeah yeah we're
Boomers to them right exactly it's like
we well no we're not we made you right
and uh that's what I say to Millennials
like I'm a millennial like okay Boomer
what all right yeah you take pride in
not knowing anything that came before
you that's weird we'll get into that in
a month yeah it's very upsetting yeah
but I think there's an element to that
where then it becomes you know you're
going into Data you're not really
there's not a maturity now that comes
until you're 30. like so regardless of
where the biological clock is at you're
not ready to do these things because
you're just you the growth isn't there
right and I think also when you bring in
stuff like pornography yep there's that
element where you the actual sex act is
not the same as the thing that you've
been getting you know through your
through puberty really yeah until you
actually and that's disappointing to me
men possibly to women I'd you know I
don't know because we did a segment your
brain on porn Gary was a doctor was it
Gary Wilson I can't remember his name oh
we talked about that where they have
thousands of sexual climaxes before
they've actually had a sexual
interaction with a woman a lot of gay
men and men now are saying young men are
saying that juice isn't worth the
squeeze I don't want to be falsely
accused of something I don't want to be
fleeced I don't want to lose my shirt so
you know what I'll just play video games
and use pornography and it is a second
adolescence and you know what a
brilliant Ploy is hey make sure that
everyone goes to college and it's paid
for by the government so that they are
basically experiencing four years of
glorified alcoholism until 22 at the
minimum well that's what I mean you're
essentially doing High School twice at
this point right because it's really not
this Institute of Higher Learning like
at least you would take your your
college seriously at some point you'd
party but there's always even if you
watch old movies it's still about
studying to some degree right and then
maybe you go on so but by the time
you're 30 you just stop being a kid
right like things have just shifted and
that's how it appears yeah called second
adolescence but he's saying no serious
guys until that's mean that means you
don't even start thinking about it yeah
absolutely and we've just become I mean
we've been selfish do you always kind of
kind of find this funny when you look
back at previous generations people that
are in there maybe 60s 70s 80s and they
tell you their life story my parents got
married at 15 and 16. my dad was working
a full-time job when he was 13 years old
right gross violation of children but
just a different mentality like there
were consequences to their actions there
was responsibility right there were
people telling them that if you want to
get ahead in life you have to work hard
nothing's going to be given to you not
everybody went to college that was
looked at as something that hey some
people can go to college I'm gonna go
learn a skill and a trade and become
very good at what I do and make a pretty
good comfortable living for the rest of
my life doing it right not anymore we've
told people that you're entitled to
everything you can be lazy don't do
anything serious until you're in your
30s you're making terrible life
decisions for people and you're doing it
for control and you're also not
celebrating the differences we say we
want to sell not at all we want to
celebrate diversity as it relates to
what race as it relates to uh sex I'm
sorry gender I'm sorry sex as it relates
to sexual orientation why do we assume
that it's right for all people to go to
college and to get a master's degree
degree and to saddle themselves with
that why don't we assume that it would
maybe be comparable to uh the rest of
all of human history that some people
it's perfectly fine they should maybe
join the military some people should
learn a trade some people should start a
business not everyone needs to go to
university but we do know that if you go
to university it is going to stall your
development on a personal level as far
as relationships people tend to not be
engaged in long-term relationships which
is different a lot of people used to
actually have a high school sweetheart a
college sweetheart now we've been
encouraged no no go out and experiment
by the way that is something that
biologically is natural for me it
doesn't mean it's right
right women typically the the norm want
to have a lot of sex with one guy they
want to lock down one guy that's kind of
the goal someone who's a good provider
someone who is a good man who will keep
their children safe and men want to have
sex once with a lot of women
that's the way we're wired it doesn't
mean it's right we have to curb some of
our natural Basic Instincts right that
it's a constant struggle if you believe
that human beings are inherently flawed
if you believe that everybody is perfect
and God doesn't make mistakes is the
philosophy which is totally different
from what we're talking about but that's
what they use as cover for everything I
want to go on puberty bloggers uh God
doesn't make mistakes okay all right
your your justification is as good as
mine we've empowered women by saying hey
let's let's uh let's turn them into men
it's why female action heroes don't work
they don't work superheroes okay
superpower is fine but you can't Empower
women by saying that they're just as
good as a man at things that men do
better than women they're things that
women women do much better than men of
course being physically strong is not
one of them for proof see pull-ups like
bacon showing not having an opinion yep
being Barefoot in the kitchen yeah
probably hot in the lawn I used to be
able to say being pregnant but now I
guess that The Field's open on that one
yeah I guess that was ruined yesterday
when you got some competition when I
gave him being pregnant yes men can get
pregnant too and you just go oh uh all
right okay fine so I do want to hear
from you guys we'll be taking your chats
a little bit later it is concerning to
see this kind of advice being gold out
and that this is the state of our
culture women are miserable men don't
want to engage with women and you know
what you lose your Society if you lose
the nuclear family and it's been very
clear and I can't say that there's a
concerted effort where they've all had a
meeting behind our backs but again if
you look at every single policy
all of them let's just say through
happenstance from the left if they had
their way would be detrimental would be
corrosive toward the nuclear family
talking about abortion talking about
abort uh talking about divorce laws
talking about student loan forgiveness
no matter what the degree is and no
matter how long you attend University
talking about the advice of don't get
married until you're in your 30s talk
about placing a priority on the
professional workspace as opposed to
your personal workspace if you look at
all of the policies coming from the left
maybe it's an accident every single one
seems to butt up against the idea of a
nuclear family and this is important
because with this country a lot of
people don't understand this and this is
why I talked about this with Dave room
we were talking about marriage laws a
long time ago
I know you'll save racist white guys
okay whatever the founding fathers I
think they got some things right most
things right but they understood that
for us to have a limited government
Society before federal government before
state government before municipal
government you had to have
self-governance and that's why they
believe that the nuclear family was a
central building block to a free society
and that's why we had marriage laws that
encouraged it because they believed that
that was what was best
four people four families four
communities and now he said no no no no
we were maybe wrong about that well what
data do you have that says you were
wrong about that all of the evidence
that we have from the last 40 years it's
made women less happy more suicidal more
miserable it's not a good thing I think
that's really what it boils down to is
your life any better
or do you think it would be better if
you follow the advice of the Kamala
harrises of the world you know one
percent of the Democratic primary vote
hey I also forgot uh
go to prep with crowder.com did you guys
see this it's the food supply do I have
it yeah yeah it's 250 off on a three
month emergency food supply prep with
credit.com that's actually the lowest
price in uh in like 10 years something
like that what was that giant tub you
gave the kids for Halloween oh I don't
know what's in there is that like a
three month supply because that that
looks like a one month I think I might
have put some of the supplies in there
and the rest was sand what I think
they're looking yeah we're all gonna
need them yes you just put glasses yeah
all right so this brings us on to
anything else you guys want to actually
we can go on to the economy let's go on
to the economy because Joe's screwing
that up too yes
yay everything Joe touches well recoils
this is have you noticed who uh this is
happening it really does the economy
recoiling there's like a Schoolhouse
Rock like teaching oh no yeah
[Laughter]
I'm sure there's a Schoolhouse Rock
thing about supply side economics I have
no idea there's got it well oh he's a
creepy pedophile I want to stay in
committee oh
yeah dollar bill's just shrinking what's
happening to me
good news young female Bill you've been
sold his property to former Vice
President Joe Biden oh
[Laughter]
he's gonna do all sorts of things to you
oh boy we yearn for the days of just
being staffed to Bill Clinton how far
are we falling with dark times okay so
yesterday while eating an ice cream cone
oh
former Vice President Joe Biden said
that he wasn't uh at all and this is how
you see how out of touch they are that
he's not concerned about the economy uh
just listen to him articulated
I'm not concerned about this Mission
Bellow I'm concerned about the rest of
the world
[Music]
inflation is worldwide
worse off everyone else in the news in
the United States so the problem is the
lack of economic growth
sound policy in other countries not so
much others and that's how it's
worldwide inflation is consequential
just for the record as you know ice
cream cones do create brain freeze not
dementia
[Music]
oh you hadn't the problem is the rest of
the world is making bad decisions I just
know that you know he was told that he'd
be rewarded at the end of the day with
that waffle yeah yeah he was he's like I
gotta answer questions nope yes
they gotta bother me I'm looking forward
to this all day oh come on man
even hold you taking a bite he's like
yeah
gosh my brussels sprouts now you're
ruining
I think my teeth my fault come on it's
soft oh it's easy to gum
come on look at how not crowded this
place is my economy's right the
president's in here and no one's in here
yes get an ice cream that's how great
everything's going yes it's like they
like a school of fish moving around a
shark oh my God by the way exact same
day Bloomberg economics projected a not
mostly not just High a 100 chance of a
recession in the next 12 months you know
oh it's really interesting they come out
with a prediction of the next 12 months
being a recession when we're already in
a recession by definition yeah sorry
well this one's super bad yes is it
different uh sorry you meant to say
Super Sound Super Sound super strong as
hell strong as hell origami strong
they're the problem no it's like China
who has our money yeah I got five
million and then they said Son yeah I'm
not supposed to say that did I say that
they funneled me back you know why
economy's fine because I'm fine yeah
yeah you're maybe not
you're probably not I got money I only
raise taxes on everyone making
does no one else see this he raised
taxes on people exclusively making more
than his salary does no one else say
that how do you just pick it arbitrarily
he picked what's the presidential salary
anyone who makes more than that yeah
yeah
all right so September inflation was 8.2
percent okay uh as far as the you over
year and actually there are different
metrics it would significantly higher
that's the best number they pull out uh
they pull out Energy prices and food I
believe to get core inflation I'm like
oh yeah nobody has to pay for those I
understand the most significant costs
yeah yeah oh yeah yeah yeah I understand
that those things vary greatly
throughout the year but in Pre in
situations where Energy prices are going
really really high and food is high
people still have to pay it so it's
inflation so yeah and by the way when
adjusted for inflation wages are
actually down
three percent year over year
so let me give you a few figures on
inflation just so you know and then
we'll get to why Joe Biden is actually
avoiding discussing the economy he was
cornered here people are like three
percent that doesn't sound a lot like a
lot you typically get about a four or
five percent raise yearly yeah that's
what most people get unless you're doing
something much different than you did
the year before three to five percent
sometimes six percent most of your raise
is gone right from that you're
purchasing power is down three percent
not including how it's affected by
energy yeah and is it what is it they
exclude energy and food and food almost
the essentials
well they only pick the things you need
to live yes because without heat you die
of the cold and without food you know
you starve well you know it's all part
of the part of the anti-human climate
agenda and I'm kind of someone it is so
they're anti-human they want you dead
that's the ideal scenario and I'm not
saying that's why inflation is terrible
I think it's because they're incompetent
but let's be honest the Democrats had
their way fit perfectly you'd be dead
and we'd have massive numbers of uh
undocumented migrants as a new voter
base that is the goal read the green new
deal it's only like four pages you can
do it in about six minutes written in
cran yes yes in the back of a place Matt
by AOC right yeah and she didn't even
get the maze right no never does so here
in uh here in uh for example North Texas
as an example uh we have inflation
figures housing is up 10.6
Transportation over 13 household energy
is up 31 and I'd like to hear your
energy costs I heard this from Reuters
this morning I don't have it in front of
me like the utility costs this winter
will be 200 something dollars higher
than last year comment below what you're
seeing as far as your costs right now
we'll go back to the Jimmy Carter days
of just wear sweater now let's compare
this more than doubled has it already
yes yeah more than done mine's about
double ready yeah really yes yeah we
haven't even gotten into the worst of it
no doubled I didn't mine hasn't doubled
but I'm incredibly cheap you're a jerk
you should suffer as much as I the cold
and dark is cheap and Stephen liked it
oh that's true you do keep your place
really cool now uh let's compare this
here's the thing where he tries to
compare for the rest of the world yes to
compare to the rest of the world I have
a space heater
[Laughter]
[Applause]
no problems at all and a dehumidifier it
works wonders
let's compare it to former vice
president sorry we have the former Vice
President Joe Biden let's compare it to
president Trump let's not just compare
it to the rest of the world but we do
have some a b comparisons okay so real
wages under buying they're down you know
anywhere we've talked about how you're
purchasing power down three percent but
real wages are down 8.5 percent
nationally according to the New York
Post and the Federal Reserve okay Donald
Trump they were up five percent the
average salary increase I don't have the
source in front of me I'm sure you guys
can get it there in the the edit Bay uh
over five thousand dollars in the first
three years of Donald Trump
as opposed to I believe it was 1 000
something uh dollars under eight years
of Barack Obama in this case they're
actually down let's look at the gas
prices again what we're talking about
the economy under former Vice President
Joe Biden 387 under Donald Trump at
similar uh a similar point in time as
presidency 257 the Consumer Price Index
under Biden it's uh over 13.2 percent in
two years for Donald Trump at 7.6 in
four years geez these are incredibly
this is I think this is the most
dramatic swing short of World War II
that we've seen uh certainly In Our
Lifetime in the United States oh yeah it
should be going the other way though
right so if you had told me right now
that Joe Biden was President leading up
to covet and this was what was happening
to the economy at the very beginning of
covet becoming a problem I would expect
that and then Donald Trump was the guy
who came when the economy opened up and
so of course the numbers are going to go
up and everything's going to be much
better when former Vice President Joe
Biden yeah no no I'm saying right now he
has everything every Tailwind you could
possibly want the world just reopened
your number should be amazing yeah no we
thought that it hit rock bottom and that
was a political Ploy and now then they
came in we're like oh my gosh there's
another Rock Bottom there's more rock
down at the bottom
there is no bottom there is no bottom
and usually you're judged harshly as a
president if you haven't seen the
increase to be greater than inflation in
other words it consistently goes up
wages this is almost unheard of of wages
going down we're talking about your
purchasing power in relation to
inflation but usually wages go up and
you're seen as a failure if they don't
go up enough to sort of keep up with the
costs of goods and services they're
going down
so when we used to criticize uh for
example uh Barack Obama you'd say well
if you actually look at the increase in
wages for example it's only one thousand
dollars under eight years Donald Trump
over five thousand dollars in three
years now we're saying it's a net
negative the severity cannot be
overstated and by the way this is how
you know they're so disconnected from
the average American the two most
important issues right now to voters
according to a new Harvard Harris poll
inflation 37 percent economy and jobs 29
that's what Americans care about right
now this is what affects most of you
that's usually the case in a national
election but it's absolutely the case
right now and he knows it's terrible
when he's not being caught off guard
with his butter pecan waffle cone yes so
he's focusing on everything other than
the economy have you noticed before
midterms he's focused on buying your
votes so good example student loans
applications for the 20 000 student loan
forgiveness program they opened uh I
believe it was yesterday I don't know if
it's today uh I think it's going to cost
us about 200 million dollars if I'm not
mistaken there are different estimates
but it's going to be you know give or
take a couple hundred million dollars
billions I think no I said just say
millions that Millions I thought it was
oh I'm an idiot admonish me I meant
billions oh I think it's the bill no
it's definitely the billions please hit
the admonish button
admonish you're like Dr Evil hold on
hold on
let me savor it
one million dollars and everybody just
laughs like yeah I got that
okay I mean 100. all right that's better
than the topless Tuesday that that is
the greatest reverse psychology I was
like guys don't admonish me ah
yes
again yes
I'm spitting the show man now
oil prices under former Vice President
Joe Biden uh this is another example he
is going to release another 10 to 15
million barrels from the Strategic
Reserve is what he's going to do of
course there's a guy who shut down a lot
of drilling where they say actually
increase more drilling on Federal Land
anyone else but that's because he shut
down more than anyone yeah it's really
hard to get a handle on a lot of these
numbers because of covet again this was
by Design uh the economy was created so
that there could be a rebound effect no
one really expected there to be no
Rebound in for it to get worse yeah you
know we tend to hang on to a lot of oil
for and the Strategic petroleum reserves
Wars nuclear Wars potentially or maybe a
war in the Middle East we tend to hold
on to it but we're at a 40-year low I
think sometime this month we're supposed
to hit the 40-year low number all
because Joe Biden wants to buy your vote
that's the most important thing here's
what I think everyone needs to kind of
understand
former Vice President Joe Biden and the
Democrat they do not care about you and
their policies will hurt you for example
Joe Biden tried to pressure OPEC to
withhold this decision to cut production
until after midterms now the White House
denied it he specifically asked until
after the midterms why is that so evil
that tells you that this former vice
president does not care that your gas
prices go up that your food prices go up
that your energy prices go up that they
Skyrocket that's not what bothers them
so long as he wins the midterms think
about what that tells you it's not how
can I solve the problem for Americans
it's how can I hide the problem until
the midterms so that I'm not embarrassed
this is a person who does not care about
you he cares about the greater good of
the democratic party which does not look
out for the interest of the American
people this is we're at that point right
now think about Bane Batman the elites
when he's going hey look can you just
can you just uh hold off until the
midterms and afterwards you can do
whatever the hell they want White House
denied it then according to the thought
he said themselves they released they
released a document it said the
government of the Kingdom clarified
through its continuous consultation with
the U.S Administration that all economic
analysis indicate that postponing the
OPEC plus decision for a month so they
didn't say midterms but in this release
all references available
decision to postpone it for a month
why why just for a month according to
what has been suggested who would
suggest it would have had negative
economic consequences
so there's also a lie he doesn't care
about you he says can you just post one
until after midterms he said I I never
said that then the son's going like yeah
yeah he did say that we're not going to
do it
[Laughter]
I think how many times you have to be
caught side is going like why would we
bring it up yes
I mean why would we not I mean I just I
didn't pull this out of the blue yes I
did I didn't even want to break I want
to discuss this this is kind of
uncomfortable for me
this is on you you've put me in an
untenable position and I'm a terrorist
yes I know no I know
it's on a camel yes
where's my ticking sport coat yes thank
you now it's my shoe bombs yes I Funny
fit one is a nine one is an eleven
one is a ski
Snowshoe really the point is is doesn't
you need not concern it's a cultural
difference we do this in Saudi Arabia
it's fun yes they ignore the ticking so
in case you're saying oh that's racist
maybe a little bit but uh here's
actually
the Saudis rejecting Vines request
saying that uh he would face
consequences here's where it comes from
we should we should and I am oh this is
him first in the process when the when
the uh this house incentive gets back
they're going to have to uh there's
going to be some consequences for what
they've done with Russia okay well the
Saudis pushed back
by offering their own consequences and
here's the thing whatever the negative
stereotype is that we're not supposed to
make jokes about okay
yes
challenges the existence of this country
and this Kingdom
all of us we are projects of jihad and
martyrd and martyrdom
I even did that things that you can
threaten us I love that guys like yeah
he's a hype man yeah
he was auditioning for for uh Saudi
terrorist deaf Comedy Jam that's what
was going on right there yes
that's it oh [ __ ]
Joe you have that I ain't scared of you
mother efforts
of September Kingdom
I am the one who crafts I'm the
Storyteller you come right out of this
shoot I have to build to murder them
instead of hamburger is just homos he's
like hold on oh mask you do know Martin
means you die right I'm not sure if we
want that on the brochure yes well
that's no it's for you matter them you
said it yes not me you said it yes I was
saying it for you well you shouldn't
have taken a row of martyr hype man I
don't know he's here I thought I was
vice president no no your mother yes so
here's the thing my focus on the
policies on appeasing the party right
now which is die this is where we are
it's diametrically opposed to you the
American people the best interest of you
he's hurt America and he's made the
world a more dangerous place now I just
saw this on CNN where they were saying
you know Donald Trump sure maybe he
didn't start any new Wars but uh we
almost had World War III
how yeah where
Russia's threatening nukes now if we
can't agree that he is the only
President in modern American history
factually who hasn't who didn't start
any new Wars isn't that I mean that's a
good thing it's just really everything
is politicking at this point and
unfortunately there is one party that is
diametrically opposed to your best
interest they're more concerned with
getting your kids on puberty blockers
and then they blame you and guess let
you think well why do you care about
that aren't there more pressing issues
sure let's talk about the economy I
can't talk to you about that why not
because you're a stranger
[Laughter]
I want to talk about the one that Trump
almost started by actually going and
talking to dictators and trying to uh
fix the situation I I hear your concerns
and I want to Circle back to that have
you seen our new uh student loan
giveaways yes yes oh not bad by the way
look I understand that inflation is
normally tied to government spending a
lot of times that's pumping too much
money into the economy and overheating
but we we just don't agree with that so
we're going to put more money into a
really inflated economy yes but that
should work just fine yeah and by the
way a really important point to
researchers when we were talking about
this they made this point when Biden
says it's a crazy manga crowd that's
another thing he wants to draw your
attention to the crazy mugger I'm not
talking about moderate Republicans who I
work with all the time zero voted for
the inflation reduction yeah none what
does that tell you are all of them magra
Republicans that includes by the way the
list change the world
none
so who's the extremist yeah can you
think of anything
I honestly can't think of something I'm
sure there is but nothing comes to mind
uh as far as a greater perversion of
being a public servant than asking a
foreign government to just just just put
that off just punt that until midterms
so I can win I don't care what happens
after that
uh
I I can't think of something not only
more evil but that is throwing you under
the bus well that is Barack Obama's
Playbook do you remember when he said to
Putin after the election I'll have more
flexibility I'll actually be able to do
what I want to do without having to pay
the political price for doing it look
Donald Trump understood that when
America is strong the world is a safer
place
Joe Biden and Barack Obama did not
understand that fundamentally when
America is strong the world is a safer
place because people are in check more
they don't have as much leverage on us
right when they do they can do whatever
they want and we can't do anything about
it right when Saudi controls the price
at the pump essentially because they
control how much oil is coming out of
these massive production companies in
all these different countries we have to
deal with that problem when we're not
pumping it here we have it here well
yeah well you understood that yeah you
can't be a global superpower if nobody's
afraid of you right
you also can't be a global superpower if
you're dependent on everyone else here's
the thing exactly so let's say we didn't
have the natural resources let's say
that we didn't have access to oil and
energy there are a lot of smaller
countries for example uh in Europe or
even you have these countries of course
they have to pick any other continent
the thing is we basically are a
continent plus Canada and Mexico yeah
whatever but the point is the United
States is big enough we have everything
here not only every climate but we we
have pretty much every natural resource
that we would need to not only feed our
own people to not only Power the energy
that we need for our own people but to
be a net exporter of all of it those
guys threatening martyrdom and the teddy
bears have their picnic hats they would
not
it couldn't be less relevant if we just
said you know what we're going to open
up access to all of our own energy and
do you think the environment is better
off with the Saudis
holding all the cards
it's it's an issue that that obviously
boggles the mind but again it's all
politicking at your expense and there's
a real problem I'm concerned that right
now we have people especially after
covid the people who saved the people
who are financially responsible when you
say well hold on a second who who's hurt
by student loans who's hurt by insert
entitlement program here how about the
people who saved how about the people
who said hey instead of relying on the
government for a student loan I'm gonna
go to a trade school I'm going to save
up because I want to become I don't know
a home provider I'm going to rent some
properties oh wait there's rent
forgiveness oh wait I'm actually
disincentivized from saving because
someone else can just have that forgiven
through what my tax dollars
it's not a never-ending supply of money
and we see when push comes to shove
behind closed doors they will take
actions meaning they this Administration
right now that fly in direct opposition
to your best interest and ironically
that means against the best interest of
the world yep but you may not like it
like it I was raised in Canada there's
an incredible jealousy complex if the
United States is well off the rest of
the world is well off do you know how I
know because you guys had a hissy fit
when the United States was maybe
considering under Donald Trump pulling
out of NATO which was a bluff but the
point is NATO is basically yeah yeah
let's uh the United States us too we
want to be protected we foot the bill
for the rest of the world
and then we screw our own people and
you're called a racist if you say you
know what I just think we should look
out for Americans first
I'm worried about the cultural shift of
disincentivizing financial
responsibility you are punished if
you're a contributor and you are
rewarded if you are a taker why because
they want to buy your votes at least
until midterms and then the chickens
come home to Rooster is it the roosters
come home to chicken I have no idea
share the show we're gonna go to mug
Club if you share it right now it's
caring helps with the algorithm here on
YouTube and hit like all that stuff is
anything else that I'm missing
all right YouTube
you want to say a channel this time
go ahead
piss off
[Music]